[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
il était une fois une paire de
chaussures qui étaient mariés ensemble
elle habitait une belle boîte en carton
où elle était enroulé dans du papier de
soie la chaussure droite qui était le
monsieur s'appelait nicolas et la
chaussure gauche qui était la dame
s'appelait tina
elle s'y trouvait parfaitement heureuse
et elle espérait bien que cela durera t
mais voilà qu'un beau matin on voit une
très jolie paire chère madame je pense
qu'elle vous iront très bien
c'est ainsi que nicolas et tina marques
chères toute une journée sans se voir
l'un l'autre le soir enfin il se
retrouvait au fond d'un placard c'est
toi tina oui c'est moi nicolas à quel
bonheur tu croyais perdu
moi aussi j'étais au pied droit
j'étais au pied gauche ah je comprends
toutes les fois que tu étais en avant
moi j'étais en arrière
et lorsque de huit ans en arrière moi
j'étais en avant c'est pour cela que
nous ne pouvions pas nous voir mais
cette ville à voir recommencer chaque
jour je le crains c'est affreux écoute
puisque je suis toujours à droite et toi
toujours à gauche
chaque fois que j'avancerai je ferai en
même temps un petit des gardes ton côté
comme ça
nous nous tirons bonjour d'accord
d'accord ainsi qu'il le sorte que le
jour suivant
très inquiète la dame à la consulter un
médecin pas de cachettes docteur je ne
sais pas ce que j'ai je ne fais décroche
tiens moi même mes pieds doigts croches
mon talon gauche et cela me fait honte
mais c'est ok mais c'est très grave si
cela continue manom il faudra vous
couper le pied droit
voici une ordonnance donnez-moi dix
mille francs anciens pour la
consultation et revenez me voir demain
tu entendu ce qu'a dit le docteur si on
coupe le pied droit de la dame l2
jettera nous serons séparés pour
toujours écoute puisque je suis à gauche
demain c'est moi qui ferai un écart à
droite chaque fois que j'avancerai
d'accord d'accord et le deuxième jour de
plus en plus inquiète la dame retourna
chez son médecin
docteur docteur maintenant c'est moche
mais c'est de plus en plus grosse armada
si cela continue il faudra vous coupez
les deux pieds revoici une ordonnance
dinars si le couple et de pied de la
dame
qu'allons nous devenir je ne veux pas y
penser
et pourtant je t'aime qu'il a mon signe
que là je t'aime je voudrais ne jamais
quitter non plus
il n'avait ainsi dans l'obscurité de
leur placard sans se douter que la dame
qui les avaient achetés se promenait
dans le couloir
en partant tôt
elle entendit
elle comprit tout à c'est donc ça ce
n'est pas moi qui suis malade
ce sont mes chaussures qui s'aiment a
commencé
là dessus elle jeta à 14 heures tous les
médicaments qu'elle avait acheté et à
plat sa femme de ménage
pepita vous voyez cette paire de
chaussures je les mettrai plus mais je
veux les garder quand même alors cyril
et bien qu'elle soit toujours brillante
et surtout ne les séparait jamais l'une
de l'autre
alors alain des x men des six chiots
sont les maîtres d'art une quinzaine de
jours quand elle les aura oublié je lis
pour lui l'arrêt et quinze jours plus
tard elle les veaux là et se limite au
pied mais un soir dans l'escalier de
service
nicolas et tina voulurent s'embrasser et
badaboum madre mia ses chaussures elles
sont sous le soleil je ne la vois plus
les maîtres je vais les donner à ma
nièce la pépite à la nièce qui était
boiteux passé presque toutes ces
journées assise sur une chaise les pieds
joints et les chaussures et est heureuse
car elle était le plus souvent côte à
côte
cela durera longtemps mais un soir tina
dit à nicolas
sans ma semelle qui devient fip vite
je vais bientôt être père ne fait pas ça
si on nous jette nous allons être
séparés pour toujours
c'est bien je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
vieillir qu'allons nous devenir
c'est pas si seulement j'étais sur deux
pattes quitté approche toi prends madrid
avec la tienne de toute façon ne seront
jamais séparés c'est ainsi qu'ensemble
ils furent jetés à la poubelle et
abandonné dans un terrain vague
il y restèrent ensemble jusqu'au jour où
un petit garçon et une petite fille qui
passait par là
allili regarde les chaussures à son bras
dessus bras dessous c'est quel son mari
ensemble à bas puisqu'elle son mari
ensemble avant faire leur voyage de neuf
avis haussier c'est ainsi que nicolas et
tina qui n'attendait plus rien de
l'existence sûrs quand même un beau
voyage de noces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]